Danny is on YouTube Dave can you give me
some pointers on how to budget on a near
regular income I tried I can't get to
work but I don't want to give up yet
well you can't give up
everyone budgets on an irregular income
everyone does
some are more extreme than others I mean
if you have two full-time regular jobs
but you get paid every two weeks you
have two months a year that your income
is different because you have those two
magic months that you get three checks
you get paid over two weeks so everyone
has an irregular income so the place you
start is you don't try to use a budget
template where every month is the same
because they're just not the same so
we're gonna look at this month and we're
gonna do the best we can to estimate our
income for the month low and we're gonna
do a regular budget on that whatever
doesn't whatever we didn't do that we'd
still like to do pay extra on debt go on
vacation I don't know what it is but
we're going to need to do some stuff
that didn't make the cut on that budget
from the estimated lower average of this
coming month whatever didn't make that
cut you just make a list of those things
most important to least important if you
make a little bit more money than what
you budgeted what's the first thing
you're gonna go to write a 1 beside that
what's the next thing you're gonna do 2
beside that what's the next thing you're
gonna do write a 3 beside that and so on
down the list and when you get you know
when you've got that list then you can
just use that to reset your every dollar
app is going and make some changes you
can do it once a week you do it once a
month you know twice a month I don't
care but and depending on how volatile
your income is as to how often you're
gonna have to update that list and
update your budget but that's how Sharon
and I have done it
our whole working lives we have never
had a 100% fixed income as a matter of
fact most people don't when you really
think about it